لاستهداف اليات الاحتلال بقذائف
ومزل منزل يتحصنون فيه بقذيفه التي بي جي
المضاده للتحصينات التي نشرته القسام
اليوم وفي هذا الفيديو اظن هنالك دعوه لك
للتحليل سحل حلل يا دويري ساحل نعم الان
لنعد الى بعض الفيديوهات التي نشرت عن
تصنيع المعدات العسكريه السؤال المطروح
اليست غزه محاصره من عام 86 صوره عامه
اليس حصارها مطبق منذ 2013 بصوره جازمه
قاطعه في هذه الفتره كيف
استعدت تبنت مقاربه الهندسه العكسيه وهي
التي تجيز ودول الصين الهند تتبنى مقاربه
الهندسه العسكريه بحيث تقوم
بمحاكاه الاسلحه المتاحه والمتميزه
وتصنعها دون ان تاخذها كما
ومن مصادر محدوده اذا هذه المقاومه
ولاحظنا ب بعض التصوير تصنيع بندقيه قمس
الغول كانت كمثال واضح دعني اقول من العدم
صنعوا
شيء جماعات مقاتله تعد بالالاف وقفوا ليس
امام جيش اسرائيل الم يهرع العالم الغربي
بزعامته
وقياداته
ليعيدوا يا ذلك الجسد المتهالك والذي سقط
في السابع من اكتوبر اذا هذه هي تعقيد
المعركه وهو صدق عندما قال
معركه مركبه نعم
معركه في اشاره سريعه المنطقه الشماليه
مركبه ومعقده نعم هي مرك وانا اوضحت ل سب
سبب لماذا هي مركبه الان
الخارطه نحن نشاهد الفيديو المنطقه
الشماليه وعرضت الخرائط بكثره الان الجي
جيش الاحتلال تقريبا بصوره ترقى الى
80% تراجع من الكتله كتله المباني واصبح
في المناطق الزراعيه كما يقال نعم كانه
هذه المنطقه من العطاطه بيت لاهيه بيت
حانون تل الزعتر حتى الدخول جنوب جباليا
هذه المنطقه هي التي يتواجد فيها يعني كان
نقول بالمثل الشعبي كانك يا ابو زيد
ماغزيت
كل ما فعلته تراجعت عنه بقي لك بعض القوات
المتواجده في الشيخ رضوان ستقوم بسحبها
منطقه الفالوجه